F3: There's a new report that the Biden
administration is planning what is being called
the biggest tax increase in thirty years. Now, I
want to be really careful in how I report this,
because, first of all, tax increase is a relative
term in that much of what Joe Biden wants to do
would be to undo, in some cases only some
of the Republican tax decreases of the past
decades. Also, none of what is being reported
is outside of what Joe Biden promised to do.
So we're seeing all of these hot takes about
shocking betrayal by Biden of I don't know what,
because he told us when he ran what his tax plan
was going to be. And the reports from Bloomberg
yesterday, which broke this story, that Joe
Biden's next big project is tax reform. It's
the stuff he told us he was going to do. So let's
look at it. The reported Biden tax plan priorities
are to increase the income tax rate on people
making more than 400000 dollars a year. Remember,
that's earned income separate from capital gains,
which we will get to. Joe Biden would expand the
estate tax, which we don't have the details yet.
You could expand the estate tax in two ways. You
could make it kick in at a lower level of wealth,
or you could increase the rate at which estates
are taxed. Joe Biden will. This is the report from
Bloomberg says Joe Biden will look to reduce tax
preferences on pass through businesses,
which would affect The David Pakman Show
would increase to a higher capital gains tax rate
for people making over one million dollars per
year would increase the corporate tax rate
from twenty one to twenty eight percent.
And in all likelihood, even if he were
to move on this very soon, nothing would
take effect until at least 2022 as a tax year,
meaning that you would deal with these changes
sometime between January and April 15th of
twenty twenty three. That that's right now.
And of course, that may change. Now, let's
just pick one of these, because so much of
this is being is being sort of misunderstood. The
corporate tax rate. What Joe Biden wants to do is
increase it from twenty one to twenty
eight percent, according to this report.
It's important to remember that the corporate
tax rate, number one, used to be in the mid 40s
and then it dropped to the low 40s than 35 percent
and it stood at 35 for a very long time. Then it
went to twenty one under Trump. So what Joe Biden
would do would be to only go partially back to the
longstanding corporate tax rate of 35 percent by
going to twenty eight. It's not exactly radical.
And then just as importantly, there's so many
people saying going to twenty eight percent will
hurt small businesses. This is a fundamental
misunderstanding. Of most small businesses,
most small businesses, if you're a sole
proprietor, if you are an LLC or an S corporation,
this doesn't affect you because all of those
business entities are taxed at the personal rate.
What I mean by that is if you have a personal
housecleaning business and you make sixty thousand
dollars, you don't pay a twenty one or twenty
eight or 35 percent corporate tax rate. You
are taxed on that sixty thousand dollars on the
personal income tax rates. Now my prediction is
that politically a lot of this stuff is going
to be really tough right now because of the
pandemic. And we'll talk to Bill Share about
this a little bit later on on the program.
Of course, Republicans are all going to say we
should never do tax increases, but in particular,
we shouldn't do them right now because of
the pandemic. There are also going to be some
Democrats who will make that case, particularly
in the Senate. I do think that increasing the
corporate tax rate is the easiest thing to do
that Joe Biden is proposing. I believe that
the other aspects of this are going to see
significant political difficulty. I'm not saying
it shouldn't happen. I am merely giving you my
opinion of what I predict is going to happen now.
We talked about some of the changes that that are
going to be made there in terms of pass-through
entities and different things, the tax plan.
Joe Biden is proposing, if it happens, is going
to lead to me as the owner of The David Pakman
Show, paying more in taxes. And I'm OK with that
as long as the money is being put to good use,
which it already is not. And as I've said before,
many times we could and should be rethinking our
spending priorities now. And we may not even have
to increase taxes to fund the programs that are
important to us. That's separate from whether
billionaires and millionaires should be paying
more and and they should. But of the roughly
one point five trillion dollars in discretionary
spending that the federal government does,
almost half of it is for the military. What?
That's insane. So I'm not saying have no military.
I'm not saying be weak. I'm not saying anything
other than half of our discretionary spending
shouldn't be going to the military. And that's a
conversation. That is a conversation that must be
had regardless of what the tax rate is on whoever.
Now, the question here is less an economic one
than a political one. We know that Joe Biden's
plan would be deficit negative. It would raise
more money than it would cost that that's been
analyzed by the Tax Policy Center. We know that
the question is going to be my instinct is
that you are going to see Republicans and some
Democrats come together and say it's not the right
time to do this. Let's see how it goes. For now,
the White House is simply saying, without
commenting on the Bloomberg report, anything we do
would not increase the taxes of people making
under four hundred thousand dollars per year.
That's the statement from the White House so far,
Friday, March 26th. One day membership, special,
massive blowout, huge dumps of discounted
memberships are going to be coming in
to be notified about how to take advantage of the
March 26th special. Simply get on my newsletter
by signing up at David Pakman. Dotcom will
take a quick break. And if you're on Twitter,
let me know. Do you think Joe Biden can get
tax reform done this year in the current
political climate? Find me on Twitter at
David Pakman. Let me know what you think.